lucas adore son nouveau gymnase à
l'école notre dame de grâce de montréal
il peut faire plus d'éducation physique
près des deux heures recommandées par le
ministère de l'éducation
mais ce gymnaste ne règle pas tout je ne
pourrais pas offrir deux heures
d'éducation physique par semaine à
l'enfant de l'école mais deuxième cycle
en seulement une heure parce que sinon
je manque de plage heures jeudi matin ce
groupe de l'école saint barthélemy
arrive papier de l'autre pas lyon qu'à
son tour d'éducation physique
en théorie les jeunes du pavillon d
érable en font une heure trente semaines
au lieu de 12 heures
et pour ceux qui doivent se déplacer ça
glisse à 1h10 est-ce que ça a toujours
été comme ça c'est à dire que non
absolument pas est la csdm on est
maintenant en croissance et clientèle
dans de la minute qu'on n'a plus de 25
groupes
on n'a pas des espaces à l'école privée
de saint lambert on doit jumeler les
groupes
voici deux classes de 3e année une
cinquantaine d'élèves dans le même
gymnase il ya l'espace à gérer et le
sorteur hambourg mais on était muet mais
j'ai des bouchons
il ya beaucoup de bruit en
je préfère des mouchards mulet que je
tenais à l'occasion malgré tout cette
année l'école privée il a réussi a
majoré son offre à 2 heures d'éducation
physique pour tous ces élèves
mais là non plus rien de facile
l'opposition était forte
il revient à chaque école de répartir le
temps alloué aux spécialités comme l'art
l'anglais et l'éducation physique
si on ajoute du temps pour une matière
une autre et coop quand on choisit
combien d'heures en place dans chacun
des échos c'est un enjeu qui est émotif
l'anglais on n'en voulait pas à fait
tout à fait historiquement et
culturellement pourtant l'éducation
physique aide non seulement à développer
des habiletés motrices mais aussi à
l'apprentissage de l'écriture de la
lecture et même des mathématiques
ce qu'on sait ce qu au niveau des des
recherches c'est que la maîtrise des
habiletés motrices des jeunes est
déficient est ce que cette capacité de
maîtrise ont un impact sur le rendement
académique potentiel la réponse est oui
donc parce que deux heures d'éducation
physique est suffisant en ce moment
réponse est non sl et d'affaires ont
tous été donnée
création active à l'extérieur il ya du
nouveau depuis 2010 est la mesure 15
0,23 à l'école on bouge
elle touche le quart des écoles
primaires du québec le but faire bouger
les élèves 60 minutes par jour avec des
pauses active en classe tout en variant
les activités physiques pendant les
récréations et services de garde
cette mesure suggère aussi d'augmenter
le temps alloué aux cours d'éducation
physique
suzanne laberge a sondé plus de 400
écoles à cet effet résultat
malheureusement c'est même pas 5% qui
ont pu rajouter des minutes aux cours
d'éducation physique
et voici que des écoles décès de ne pas
signer aux deux heures recommandées
d'éducation physique se disant qu'elles
ont déjà la mesure pour faire bouger
sauf que l'activité physique ne remplace
pas l'éducation physique la clé pour une
longue vie active selon plusieurs c'est
d'abord apprendre à bouger
citant une bonne coordination au culot
manuel que tu acquise en les courts du
ska ont fusé qu'une bonne habitude à
sauter ou a lancé
devrait être capable d'être plus
performante dans les sports donc ça va
être plus valorisant pour toi d'en faire
cette valorisation là c'est ce qui te
pousse à continuer à en faire plus
tendance et l'idéal aux primaires une
heure d'éducation physique par jour sans
entendre les spécialistes
le cas est bien d'accord c'est bon pour
la santé
entre temps on fait avec et si diane
sauvé radio canada montréal
et toutes les études le démontrent étude
après étude faire du sport aide aussi
dans l'apprentissage du français des
mathématiques de la sociologie des xerox
et le mot à retenir dans deux heures
recommandé par le ministère de
l'éducation du québec c'est recommandé
ce n'est pas imposé
nous avions demandé depuis cinq semaines
une entrevue avec le ministre de
l'éducation monsieur roberge pour nous
expliquer à ce qu'on devrait pas imposer
les deux heures par semaine au moins on
parle pas d'une heure par jour on
comprend pour des questions d'espacé
possible mais deux heures par semaine ça
venait de québec d'en haut
pourquoi pas la réponse
silence il décide pas venir vos adresses